الرئيس الاوكراني
هجوما لاذعا على روسيا خلال خطابه امام
زعماء العالم في الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده في نيويورك
واتهمتسكي موسكو بالتلاعب باسواق الغذاء
العالميه للحصول على اعتراف دولي بملكيه
الاراضي التي استولت عليها
منذ بدايه الحرب الشامله اغلقت روسيا
الموانئ الاوكرانيه في البحر الاسود وبحر
ازوف حتى الان تظلوا موانئنا على نهر
الدانوب هدفا للصواريخ والطائرات بدون
طيار ومن الواضح ان روسيا تحاول استغلال
نقش الغذاء في السوق العالميه سلاحه
بمقابل الاعتراف ببعض ان لم يكن كل
الاراضي التي استولت عليها روسيا تستخدم
اسعار المواد الغذائيه اسلحه ويمتد تاثير
ذلك من ساحل المحيط الاطلسي في افريقيا
الى جنوب شرق اسيا
زعماء العالم ان يقفوا متحدين ضد الغزو
الروسي وقال انه يجب صد موسكو التي اتهمها
بالابتزاز النووي ودفع العالم نحو حرب
نهائيه حتى يتمكن العالم من التحول الى حل
التحديات العالميه الملحه
تعمل روسيا على استخدام طاقه النوويه
سلاحه فهي لا تقوم فقط بنشر تقنيات بناء
محطات الطاقه النوويه لا يعتمد عليها
ولكنها تعمل ايضا على تحويل محطات الطاقه
في البلدان الاخرى الى قنابل قادره حقيقيه
انظر الى ما فعلته بمحطه توليد الكهرباء
في جابولوجيا قصفتها احتلتها والان تبتز
الاخرين بالتسريبات الاشعاعيه فهل هناك اي
معنى لخفض الاسلحه النوويه في حين تعمل
روسيا على عسكره محطات الطاقه النوويه